[Música]
Carrusel de las artes
María Carolina piña
[Música]
reciban un cordial saludo desde París Ya
estamos listos para presentarles nuestro
Carrusel que en esta ocasión nos hará
descubrir algunas tradiciones y nuevas
voces africanas y los misterios de la
condición femenina
Circo música y percusiones es el cóctel
de café concierto un espectáculo que
rescata las tradiciones de Guinea para
mostrarlas al mundo
un monólogo sobre la sexualidad femenina
con una pizca de humor y psicoterapia se
llama para que te ames aún más y
nosotros conversamos con su autora e
intérprete la actriz Trinidad
en los estrenos del cine francés dos
dramas protagonizados y dirigidos por
mujeres
y en la crónica musical conoceremos a
los ganadores de un galardón de nuestra
casa el premio rfi que se entregó en
nuestra emisora
[Música]
los invitamos a descubrir a una compañía
de circo fuera de lo común y que le ha
aportado diversidad a la escena circense
producción Escalante fue fundada por
yamuza bangura y fuimos a conocerlos en
el festival de Montreal de la mano de
Melisa barra
en la ciudad de Montreal una compañía de
circo vibra al son de los tambores
guineanos creada en 2017 producción
kalamante es una de las formaciones que
conforman la ciudad internacional de
artes circenses un polo de referencia
mundial a la que también pertenece el
uso ley llamo usa bangura es el director
artístico de kalavante
por Montreal es la capital mundial del
Circo trabajé para casi todos los circos
que beckenses y en un momento sentí que
me faltaba mi lado africano con sus
instrumentos su energía y sus acrobacias
por eso decidí crear
[Música]
nuestro espectáculo africancías que
tiene de todo música africana guiada por
la cora y las percusiones tenemos
grandes tambores llamados dudum son la
base el corazón de la música africana
la carrera de vancoura comenzó en los
años 2000 en el circo baobab en Guinea
la primera compañía de acrobacias aéreas
de África inspirada en los palets
africanos del coreógrafo y compositor
fodevaqueta
[Música]
tenemos de todo buenos músicos
percusionistas y grandes acróbatas no se
puede hablar de cultura guineana sin
mencionar los ballets africanos un arte
que a partir de los años 60 representó
al continente africano en todo el
planeta
[Música]
fundó a su vez en 2007 producción
kalamante también abri la escuela de
circo en su país de origen para intentar
cambiar las mentalidades
[Música]
a las mujeres a trabajar en los circos
nuestros padres pensaban que las volvía
estériles nosotros los jóvenes estamos
luchando contra esos estereotipos dos de
mis hermanas Son contorsionistas ya
hemos graduado tres promociones en la
escuela y vemos que la nueva generación
en África está tomando el relevo
[Música]
y del Circo vamos al teatro para
conversar con una actriz que ha escrito
un espectáculo tan cómico como
inspirador ella se llama Trinidad y
durante una hora y media nos cuenta la
construcción de la feminidad desde su
historia personal un show picante
motivador humano para reír y reflexionar
[Música]
bueno
la heroína de este espectáculo se llama
Trinidad y ha puesto toda su elocuencia
humor y energía en un One Woman show un
espectáculo de una sola mujer para que
te ames aún más
a través de su historia personal de hija
de españoles nacida y criada en Francia
en plena Liberación femenina Trinidad
habla sin pelos en la lengua de
sexualidad de amor E invita a
reflexionar sobre nuestros propios
traumas y superarlos un espectáculo
necesario frente a los acontecimientos
de nuestra época Me parece que hace
falta después de la historia de mí tú
porque la que la palabra de la mujer
fuese libre Eso me parece fenomenal pero
lo que vi lo que constaté es que siempre
nos veían como víctimas y yo pienso que
la mujer es muy poderosa muy potente y
que hay que trabajar sobre ese tema
hacer salir La potencia de las mujeres y
yo pienso que contra más la mujer se vea
potente más podrá ver la fragilidad de
los hombres y más Nos podremos unir y
avanzar juntos Esa es mi teoría empieza
para que te ames aún más habla de
mujeres inspiradoras intelectuales
cantantes empresarias o mujeres del
espectáculo pero sobre todo de
sexualidad creo que justamente para
llegar a la potencia hay que conocer su
su Dónde está su placer dónde están sus
deseos Dónde está Qué mujer soy mi
intimidad y los hombres tienen que
hacerse la misma pregunta porque tampoco
se habla de la sexualidad de los hombres
yo he aprendido eso con comodidad eh que
los hombres También tienen sus temáticas
su miedo su supresión y creo que hay ahí
está todo cuando vamos a tener placer
sea una cosa natural porque somos así
hay que mirar a los animales y somos
animales Pues también puede cambiar la
cosa fácil
necesito sentirme útil siempre
necesitados sentirme útil siempre cuando
he subido al escenario era para para yo
digo siempre doy llavecitas cada una que
coja su llave y abra las puertas que
quiera es mi manera de ver la vida a lo
mejor podría haber sido una mujer
política pero no me interesa porque yo
lo que me interesa es el amor y la
política no va con el amor
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y a continuación destacamos dos
películas en las carteleras esta semana
en Francia dos dramas femeninos y
filmados por mujeres
llega a las salas de cine movés niñas
malas un documental conmovedor sobre un
tema muy desconocido en Francia el de
las adolescentes que vivieron en los
llamados centros de corrección dirigidos
por religiosas
[Música]
este documental de la palabra a cuatro
mujeres de diferentes edades Víctimas de
estos lugares de corrección Para Jóvenes
rebeldes o difíciles cada una cuenta su
historia y los tratos que sufrieron en
estos centros que funcionaron en Francia
hasta 1970
[Música]
Santo me dejas la cinta ganadora de dos
galardones en la mostra de Venecia y la
candidata francesa a los Oscar se ve un
poco
[Música]
su principal
la primera ficción de la muy aplaudida
Franco senegaleza alisdiov cuenta el
juicio de logos colli una madre acusada
del asesinato de su bebé en 2013 el
juicio es seguido por una novelista rama
que termina cuestionando sus propias
convicciones
esta cinta santomera explora múltiples
temas como la maternidad o el pasado
colonial de Francia Los Ángeles
[Música]
y pasamos ahora a la actualidad musical
Natalia Olivares nos lleva a descubrir
los bastidores de un premio entregado en
nuestra casa el pri rc de cuberter un
certamen que busca impulsar a nuevos
artistas sobre todo africanos
[Música]
y edición número 41 del Pri de cubag el
premio de rfi que selecciona artistas de
la escena africana y este año la
presidenta del Jurado es yemia ladez
[Música]
lo que primero miró es la originalidad
del candidato y la autenticidad de su
texto así como de su música en segundo
lugar vemos lo que el candidato puede
ofrecer al público su talento su talento
natural y final realmente me fijo en la
emoción en lo que siento al escuchar su
voz
para saber lo que está detrás de este
premio es decir nos recibe lucitivo Hola
a todos estamos en directo del programa
rfideq vengan a ver
[Música]
ahora
[Aplausos]
leche con leche conquista
confiscaránga tu madre eres túmbalele
en la fila pones la guerra referida a
conocer a los artistas que no tienen esa
posibilidad para mí ganar este premio es
muy importante y para la carrera de todo
artista que debuta también esto me va a
permitir promover la cultura malience y
la música de Mali en todo el mundo
y en este ambiente eufórico vamos a ver
a todo el equipo del Pri de cuberte la
presentadora estrella julietti ve muy
bien muy bien buenas señoras
es un trabajo que se efectúa durante
meses y meses porque no podemos Escuchar
tantas canciones
tiempo para hacer al máximo objetivo
llamamos a un máximo de candidaturas A
veces tenemos candidatos del Caribe de
Haití de Guyana del magreb también de
África subsahariana y esta vez la
ganadora es black eid artista de Mali
increíble que hace una música
tradicional y moderna ella supo adaptar
esas músicas tradicionales con algo más
moderno más nuevo para mí ella irá muy
muy lejos
Black ID se lleva 10.000 euros de premio
rc de un concierto en París y una gira
promocional suerte a ella y a todos los
participantes
[Música]
gracias Natalia Olivares y felicidades a
Black ID por ese premio con este tema
Mali Nos despedimos de ustedes
agradeciéndoles por su amable sintonía
mi archivo
[Música]
de Valiente
[Aplausos]
[Música]